India's Supreme Court has ordered an
urgent review of the lockdown in
indian-administered Kashmir while the
ruling is in response to a series of
petitions challenging the legality of
the government shutdown that includes a
ban on the internet will New Delhi
revoked the region's autonomy in August
and imposed extra security and
restrictions were uncial whopper is
joining us live now from New Delhi hi
there uncial so will this ruling that's
been made make a difference in reality
to the people of Kashmir well that we
don't have an answer to yet because the
court has ordered a review of all
restrictions many restrictions have been
lifted but some such as the internet
continue to be there now will the
government lift that restriction off
that answer no one can answer that at
the moment but what the court is
essentially said which is very
significant that any government cannot
impose internet shutdowns arbitrarily
because right to internet is a part of
article 19 in the Indian Constitution
which gives the Indian citizens a right
to freedom of expression and internet
there that's how it comes and I do have
one of the petitioners with me lawyer of
Lynda Grover man thanks very much for
joining us could you tell us in you know
in brief what does this word it actually
mean in legal terms but also for the
people of the valley I think it's a very
significant judgement I was representing
Kashmir Times a newspaper and our
contention was that the ban on internet
freedom is an assault on freedom of
speech and expression freedom of the
press and the restrictions and movement
are all in you know in have implications
for freedom of press the court had and
the state had argued that these are
issues of national security particularly
given that Kashmir is a border state
that actually is cross-border terrorism
and therefore considering security
concerns there should be no judicial
review the court has said that no these
are matters of fundamental freedom and
liberty and the court will subject every
executive action in order to judicial
review
they have said that the inter right to
internet is protected under the
Constitution as part of freedom of
speech and expression and therefore any
restriction
prohibition on internet will have to
meet the test of constitutionality to
make sure that is the executive action
proportional to the problem that it
poses
what is it excessive so is that
case-by-case then to test to the to
check the test of proportionality
between ask for security and liberty yes
the case by case it will be order by
order right now what the way the state
had conducted itself is that those
orders were not published those orders
were not even placed before the court a
few sample orders were given they have
been directed to immediately publish all
orders pertaining to Internet
restriction as well as movement
restriction those orders must contain
material particulars that why is the
state taking this measure and is this is
this required is the success rate those
are the constitutional touch points that
the court has said must be held and that
is the constituted protection it has
given to Internet freedom now how does
it mean in other cases because after
indian-administered Kashmir we've also
seen the Indian government impose
Internet shutdowns in Assam when
protests against the citizenship bill
broke out also in uttar pradesh what
does it mean for you know could the
government can the government carry on
imposing it in other areas or can they
be legally challenged well each time the
government will impose it it would be
the court has said the government must
keep these parameters in mind and has
said legitimate expression of protest
whether through movement or assembly
cannot be curtailed in this manner
section 144 which restricts freedom of
movement and freedom of assembly in fact
the court has gone so far as to say that
repeated use of section 144 which we are
now seeing across the country when there
are protests on other reasons right is
an abuse of power any arbitrary shutdown
of internet can only happen after you
publish the order right alongside and it
will be open to judicial review now very
briefly cuz I've run out of time what
does it mean for the people because I
asked this earlier I think we didn't get
to it what does it mean for the people
of indian-administered Kashmir now I
think what the court has said is that
for essential services internet must be
restored immediately all orders to be
published all orders in a time-bound
manner to be reviewed right by the
review committee under the telecom rules
and if
there do not remove them people are free
to challenge them and they will be
challenged before the respective it's
very much lower Grover they're
essentially talking about the people now
have a right to challenge any such
shutdowns immediately it would mean that
more internet connections for hospitals
and schools some have already been
restored and other top businesses but
more clarity would emerge once this
review actually happens I suppose
expected to happen as the court says in
in seven days until Vollrath joining is
there live from New Delhi
uncial thank you